three players who made a name for  themselves on the prep fields of las  vegas received a call of a lifetime  on day three of the nfl draft centennial  graduate  raimonde stevenson was selected by the  patriots in the fourth round after a  standout career  at oklahoma in the fifth round gorman  grad brevin jordan was taken by the  texans  and former desert pine star tony fields  learned he'll be a linebacker for the  browns  and it's a better feeling than he'd ever  imagined  oh man i mean to be honest  i've never expected it never thought it  and once that call hit  it it brought tears to my eyes i'll be  real man i'm ready to get called ready  for the call  then they called my dad and they're like  hey but i was like hey here  so i jumped on the phone and it was a  head coach and a linebacker coach and  he said hey jump on the zoom meeting so  we can see your face and it was the best  call of my life